chris hemsworth dishes on Halloween  plans with his kids they're very excited  eats he spoke with the father of three  on Monday in New York City at a special  screening of his new film Thor Ragnarok  where he opened up about his little ones  Halloween costumes I tried to convince  him to dress like Thor but they may be  fans of Wonder Woman and set him for  myself which is fine with me I'm the fan  of Wonder Woman  I might even dressed as her yeah  basically we bought a few options  because my kids have a set of erotic and  a change of heart constantly and yeah  and we'll see I don't know what the  official official costume choices yeah  we don't really do it at Halloween in  Australia now it's it's mainly yeah we  don't really do it so they're very  excited about the chocolates and sweets  and so on  [Music]